هناك مقطع فيديو جديد على قناة سي إن إن هذا
الصباح يظهر غارة أوكرانية
على الدبابات الروسية
خارج العاصمة مباشرة كييف
يزعم الجيش الأوكراني أنه
هزم فوج دبابة روسي
وقتل قائده ،
كما أن القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية تشارك
مقاطع فيديو في أعقاب ذلك.  كما
ترون تظهر
الدبابات المحترقة وقد دمرت ، فهم ينضمون
إلينا الآن اللواء المتقاعد في الجيش الأمريكي
بول إيتون على القائد العام السابق لفرق
تدريب المساعدة العسكرية للتحالف
في العراق صباح الخير ، من الجيد
أن تعود معنا هذا الصباح ،
نود أن  ابدأ في هذا الفيديو إذا
استطعنا ذلك الخط الطويل من الدبابات الذي
نراه والذي يثير بضعة
أسئلة تحدثت عنها أنا وجيم
قبل العرض وليس فقط ما إذا كان هذا
يبدو أنه
تخطيط عسكري ذكي أو انطلاق
من جانب روسيا ولكن  إنه
يوضح أيضًا مكان حدوث
ذلك وهذا هو صفعة في وسط
حي منازل على كلا الجانبين
ما هو رأيك بشكل عام ما نحن
عند رؤيتنا في هذا الفيديو
جيدًا ، أعتقد أننا نشاهد كمينًا منظمًا
وفي
أي وقت تضع فيه دبابات في منطقة حضرية ،
يجب أن تكون محاطًا
بمشاة ومشاة مفككين في
أحسن الأحوال
، ومن الواضح
أن قائد دبابة
فاجأه
كمين منظم جيدًا ومُنفذ جيدًا
بأسلحة دبابات ni لذا أه
إلى جانب
أي شيء يمكنك توصيله من
طائرات هليكوبتر أو
دعم جوي قريب من
شأنه أن يوفر لك المشاهد
التي لدينا الآن